hi i'm emma hi i'm heather hey i'm mary
hi i'm amanda hi i'm kristel hey guys
i'm maya vande hi i'm davina potratz hi
i'm vanessa vichela hi i'm christine
quinn and we are the ladies of selling
sunset today we're here with buzzfeed to
play a little game called who's who
[Music]
who is most likely to give the best
relationship advice hello
i said heather i was going between you
and heather and then i'm like i think
you would laugh about it and make funny
jokes so about like things so i was like
heather i said rochelle heather yeah
cause i said heather too oh
i mean she's the only one out of all of
us that are married so i think she's the
only one
[Applause]
okay you're demoted from being my best
friend of this memory i forget that
they're married because i'm part of that
you know i'm married to them too i think
i've gone through a lot of ups and downs
and i'm with my soul mate i'm like the
best place in my life so i think i have
good advice for the girls for sure i
would say me
because i'm the most successful one i'm
kidding well i'm not kidding but yeah me
maya
heather and i think it's because i talk
to her so much but um yeah i did say my
and she met my last boyfriend as a
christine as well i said vanessa because
i feel like her and i have had a lot of
relationship conversations in general
she's the one who's a lot more positive
than me and you know in terms of like
like love and like forgiving and i'm
like no but he did this so i feel like
vanessa
i love you christine well i mean heather
and i have a very similar relationship
field that we both uh found someone that
makes us feel like is our best friend
and it's a very very beautiful who is
most likely to arrive late to a work
event well we've all been late but we
have one person i think in mind that we
know one person in particular amanza
amanza
no doubt if amanza shows up on time i
have to put it on my calendar that she
actually showed up on time amanda
i love her but i do think you know she
does travel quite far compared to the
rest of us and she has two kids of
course she's a single mom so it's a lot
on her plate and i think she's working
on it we're just used to it we don't
even care we're like oh hey she'll get
here when she gets here wait till you
see season four
that's why my character was different
i'm surprised you guys said that oh wait
i said it because everyone oh she's like
hours late or disneyland yeah
i'm changing my own yeah
i am too excited you know what this was
like a funny you know what i'm actually
changing my answer christine who is most
likely to break awkward silence in the
office me
i would say me again
maya maya
and ask funny questions but i feel like
christine is good at breaking awkward
silences too so i was kind of tied
between two of them there's a lot of
times where it was like tense and then
you say something funny or you do
something funny and it kind of breaks it
up maya will be like well that was
awkward yeah yeah
yeah but maya would be like why did you
say that or i don't know
silence of the lamb the silence of the
lamb that's me
you know what it's like in hebrew we
have that saying that we're like when
everything is called we say silence of
the lamb but in hebrew obviously it's a
very famous uh movie yeah it just came
natural to me and i guess it became like
some funny stupid line who's most likely
to fall asleep at their desk
mary
i want to say again amanza i would say
because she would space out somewhere
else and think about other things and
you know she's she's a mom to two kids
and she's probably exhausted also
everyone everyone
i'd say mary because she works so much
and like super late nights and
[Music]
yeah i'm always exhausted why did i say
brett
i mean
all over me from like falling asleep at
the wheel so we don't really need
there's too much tension to sleep in our
office
you know so much anxiety and it's hard
to sleep you know who's most likely to
send a sew and sunset meme
we're always sending texts when we're in
the middle of it oh my god i did i need
you to see me
[Music]
i feel like christine and i have done
this before yeah
i do it a lot we joke around a lot so i
feel like we've done that a little bit i
don't know yeah
yeah i haven't had any memes yet so i
don't know
it's fair for me not to know
i mean i would i said heather because i
think that she is i mean she's always
standing or asking for photos and you
know like or things like that so yeah
that's um that makes sense emma would
send group memes and i would also say
christine but she's not really now in
our group chat so i said myself again i
you know what though it's because you
guys don't have me on one of your secret
little effing group chats because you
guys thought i was cooking with
christine you guys still haven't added
me to that one so
i don't think
i haven't even seen emma's memes in the
group chat because i wasn't part of the
group chat
oh my gosh we haven't seen these are
funny
you guys have a secret group too i have
a huge group chain from last night that
you were on that we're all texting on so
who chimed in besides not me i was
sleeping i think about when we're like
in the office and we're filming or
something and we're there and all of a
sudden i sound like the thing where
they're like hiding in the bush like
[Laughter]
thank you i have one i used it today on
twitter and it's mary and she goes
cheers to crazy
oh my god i wanna get it all the time
there's a lot of mean girl references so
there's a lot of funny twitter memes and
i feel like you know we are
previously we were kind of labeled that
so they were like
the funny tweets about ourselves yeah
exactly
there's a lot of funny ones like one was
like you know people were commenting on
the harry megan interview and then they
were saying buckingham palace needs to
be sold and the divino should sell it
you know for like 100 million or
whatever it was who's most likely to
flirt with a client to get the sale look
before i was married
maybe emma it's a tough one because i
think we're all very nice and
flirtatious you know we play the game a
little bit heather emma
oh i was gonna say emma yes obviously
but i don't really know her very well
but she looks like she would so yeah i
changed it to emma emma
i know emma because everyone
yeah i guess i would say myself you're
another flirt but because of what we
just did right i feel like i'm very
friendly i'm a single like
single yeah exactly no she's not yeah
and you're bubbly and funny but you
wouldn't flirt with any client but no
not any clients but
there's nothing wrong with flirting with
a client you're single who cares exactly
thank you who is mostly likely to throw
an extravagant what do you think
extravagant party for no good reason
hundred percent depends on christine
crispy
[Laughter]
i said you i don't know why but
i've missed a lot of your fun oh i just
threw one but yeah jason throws a lot
too i haven't been to christine's party
jason's the right answer for sure so
yeah they said there's a lot of parties
and they're amazing well just remember
my answer when it comes out i love to
throw a party for no reason i've done a
tiger i've done oh yeah
zebra i mean like i've done everything
davina do you remember the party that i
threw
with the belly dancers that was like the
moroccan theme that was really cool we
took my whole entire front lawn and like
you know made tents with different
hookahs and areas and belly dancers and
like fire dancers i think that was a
really fun one also um we had a sound
bath at my house and that was that was
really cool too yeah yeah so we had a
lady come over and do you know sound
bass and the drums and the whole nine
yards i think a wedding was like uh
pretty insane wearing a black dress to
your own wedding that's uh that's
extreme and also the the song she walked
through the aisle was like the cycle
song
cyclone
so christine for sure weddings that was
a great one who's most likely to retire
from real estate no one
rochelle this is your moment it's your
moment christine
i would say christine but i want to say
[ __ ] before i'm successful because
just she's gonna take you know travel
the world and have fun with her husband
and that's the reason it just doesn't
seem to be a priority do not know what
those are talking about
who's most likely to find themselves in
the middle of office drama i mean i feel
like it's you and me my friend so okay
christine
christine
i felt like i didn't know i was like
wait a minute
[Music]
i said davina what did you guys say i
said me
because i don't i don't try to but i'm
always somehow in the middle of it and
i'm like i just went out of it that's a
good point cause season one christine
was fighting about mary and the whole
christian thing that's right it's always
around mary somehow yeah because she
doesn't want to be in the drama but
somehow she's
involved in it now it's with emma yeah
she's the center of all of it so yeah
yeah
we all get long grains we actually all
had almost all different answers so
shocking i'm very shocked well actually
christine is the right answer but i i
guess i was just mary was being polite i
was like trying to think of something
else yeah because don't you guys want to
watch a fun show amen to this
no drama no show
no drama no show i mean if it wasn't for
christine we had no drama let's face it
hey christine i love christine she
provides the drama who's most likely to
mix up jason and brett well hopefully
not crochetl
[Laughter]
vanessa she still knew she still
probably doesn't know the difference
between the two of them me
yeah you're the only one that doesn't
know as well as we do and i feel like
once you know their personalities it's
very easy to tell them apart bananas
i just said mayaka's pregnancy brain
like i was
like i like that you spice it up a bit
i just only said vanessa not because
she's dumb she's new so she's had less
time to figure out the difference that's
why i said it too yeah i mean i if i see
them from afar i'm like oh of course if
i see them like oh hello
you definitely immediately yeah you know
who is who but if it's from afar i'm
like
personalities are really different
though
like oh
yeah exactly but if you're like sitting
in at the office and in the back or
whatever and they mix i mean like change
seats or whatever i have no idea who's
who who's most likely to cook dinner for
everyone else emma emma
that was easy
christy
many times for me and yeah i mean she
cooks the most extravagant meal all by
herself from scratch oh can we go crazy
i have to tell you i have to try that oh
my gosh i'll have you over i'm like
martha stewart girl emma is coming from
the food business she has this empanada
going for her so she is definitely the
chef i actually met emma when she was
cooking dinner at jason's for everyone
like six years ago or seven years ago
and i didn't know her and she made the
best dinner and the most amazing dessert
still to this day
chocolate chip cookies with the oreo in
the middle i was like who is this woman
she's so beautiful and she knows how to
cook and that was what was emma
it was a funny story because obviously i
was meeting everybody for the first time
like some people and they actually
thought i was the caterer they're like
do you have a card
yeah i said all right no i don't have a
card who's most likely to binge the
series in one sitting all over ever i
would say divina maybe just to make sure
she you know she doesn't have one line
that will score for the rest of the
season she might hate me for saying
that everyone christine maya maya yeah
yeah she was binging at hardcore yeah
yeah because like we got the email and
then within five minutes she's like oh
hey babe i know i said this one saying
but i didn't really say it like that
they edited it differently
yeah like it's fine i actually didn't
even know we had it in our email and she
texted me and was like oh check your
email and i was like oh okay yeah i feel
i'm still running through the episodes i
haven't finished it i'm dying too though
but i did zip through all the episodes
but i only skipped to my lines to make
sure i didn't say something bad about
other people i said heather because i
feel like heather's very structured with
what she does every day and like she has
like a time slot for it so i feel like
that would be after her run and her
morning vegan snacks she would binge
selling sunset and then on to like her
mini meetings and everything i just fast
forwarded and i looked in my outfits and
then i passed forward i looked at my
makeup i looked i fast
i just need forwarded go you know i mean
she really had the baby for 100
but um you look incredible yeah
incredible hey buzzfeed thank you so
much for having us and you can watch
season four of selling santa on netflix
cheers to crazy
here's the crazy that's my favorite one
[Music]
you